[Musique]
donc les méchants ce sont les skrulls
et vous vous êtes une crise d'une lignée
de nobles guerriers héroïque noble
guerrier errant week
le film m'a vraiment surpris captain
marvel elle est vraiment lé puissant
c'est la meilleure et ben maintenant on
attend d'abord la suite en fait c'est
une fille comme tout le monde finalement
à la base et et qui se rend compte
qu'elle n'a pas forcément besoin
la vie des autres pour être quelqu'un de
fort en fait et qui est forte par
elle-même donc c'est une belle histoire
choses franchement incroyable
ah oui de voir les vraiment inattendu
attendu mais pensez à temps par nancy
attend quoi la tangente attendait
beaucoup du coup je suis un peu déçu
parce que quand on attend beaucoup
quelque chose on est forcément déçu
franchement c'est un bon film s'étire et
c'est bien tirés des films qui ont été
faits avant on sent que si les
traitements de loyers liée à la
chronologie marvel et que c'est un film
qu'il faut absolument regarder avant la
suite qui est prévue pour le mois
prochain
[Musique]